this class is unlike any other that I've
ever taken in my life first I'm not only
do you get to learn from some of the
greatest people in the field who studied
so many different aspects of autism you
also get to work directly with autistic
children and you get to experience what
their daily life is like and work
one-on-one with them and in groups and
it's just such an all-encompassing
experience that I'm really excited about
well one of the reasons I came to you
was because they had such an outstanding
autism class thought has been related
disorders that I saw in the blue book
and I was really excited to take and
also because they have a wonderful
research program that I really wanted to
get involved in as soon as I could so
there are a lot of different reasons
that students want to be a part of the
class some come from a background in
neuroscience or psychology and want to
simply learn more about the condition of
autism and then each year there are a
number of students who have some
personal connection I have grown up with
an older brother who has
high-functioning autism and I've seen my
mother pretty much to about her life to
building the necessary skills for him to
hopefully one day be able to live in a
more independent setting I had heard
about the class before from several
people that had been in it and it was
very very exciting produced a few
superstars in our field so for example
warren jones got into the field of
autism by study by taking this course
and so i was very excited to be a part
of it whenever I came to you but when
dr. clin and dr. welcomer started this
class it was the first of its kind and
they start a tradition that we continue
now which is having that didactic
portion of the class paired with a
clinical component so every student who
enrolls in the class in addition to
coming to the lectures each week works
at an agency in the community pretty
much whatever has been discovered so far
in the field of autism is covered at
least a little bit and I'm really
excited because you get to learn from
the most severely autistic children to
what it's like for the most highly
functioning and every aspect i feel you
get to learn about their language skills
and their psychological development and
anything you can imagine
a number of students come through we've
had a number of students join our lab
group for research who have as a result
of being in the class being associated
with some of the research that goes on
here decided to take their own career
paths in a way that would more directly
relate to work with kids with autism
we're excited about that because it
really means it were or fostering the
same kind of enthusiasm and other
students that led us to the same point